tuvieron que pasar cerca de siete meses
para que los franceses pudieran regresar
al teatro aquí estalló el teatro
nacional de la danza fue una de las
primeras salas en parís en volver a
abrir sus puertas y durante todo este
mes de mayo estará ofreciendo
espectáculos gratuitos hablamos con
algunos de los espectadores de las
personas que vinieron a este teatro y
nos contaron que se sentía estar de
regreso me siento muy muy orgullosa de
estar aquí es mi primera salida obvia
sox y frustración desde hace un año nos
tienen cansados con estas restricciones
estoy contento de poder salir gran parte
de los cafés y restaurantes de la
capital también volvieron a abrir sus
puertas el dueño de este restaurante nos
contó cómo se preparó para la reapertura
fitch jugaba de que sus amos circuitos
muy cortos con productos que vienen
directamente de bretaña algunos habían
dejado de trabajar por eso queríamos
estar seguros de que tendríamos los
productos esa era una primera
preocupación y la segunda era saber si
los clientes regresarían porque entre la
segunda ola y la vacunación que avanzaba
lento estábamos preocupados temíamos que
la gente dejara de venir qué tipo de
presión
[Música]
antonio hay mucha expectativa de todos
los sectores del país esperando que haya
una verdadera reactivación de la
economía la siguiente etapa clave será a
partir del 9 de junio cuando comience la
segunda parte de este nuevo de es
confinamiento